BRIAN BUTTERWORTH: The first
patient that we tested
formally and in detail was
a woman who had kept the
accounts of the hotel
that her family ran.
But after a stroke which
affected her left hemisphere,
she was unable to deal with
numbers above four.
Any numbers in any way
we presented them.
I mean, if we gave her a word
for a number above four, she
wouldn't know whether it was
even a real word or not, let
alone what it meant.
What was really interesting
for us was that everything
else seemed to be fine.
I mean, her language was fine,
she could understand what we
were saying perfectly well.
She could remember what she'd
had for breakfast.
She could reason.
We gave her lots of
reasoning tests.
She was absolutely fine.
She understood symbols.
So we gave her lots of different
sorts of symbols,
like traffic signs, political
party signs and so on.
Absolutely fine.
It was just numbers
that seemed to
be selectively affected.
So we thought, well, why
is it that numbers
are selectively affected?
Because the current theory at
that time including, the
theory that came from Chomsky
was really, numbers were just
an aspect of language.
That all the capacities that you
need for language kind of
automatically gave you numbers
as well, if you bothered to
learn them.
But here you had somebody whose
language was still fine,
but her numbers were really,
disastrously badly affected.
So of course she couldn't
do her work anymore.
Then we found another patient
who seemed to have the
opposite problem.
Different kind of neurological
condition.
A kind of degenerative disease
that affected a different part
of the brain.
This affected the temporal lobes
rather than the parietal
lobes, which seem to be the
main areas for numbers.
This patient was--
language was disastrous,
completely disastrous.
If you gave him what we call a
picture pointer task, like
point to the orange,
he basically was
at chance at that.
And his speech was confined to
very stereotype phrases, just
a few stereotype phrases.
His memory for other sorts of
things seemed to be fine,
except what we call
semantic memory.
So he didn't, for example,
know that an
orange was a fruit.
However, his calculation
was superb.
If you gave it to him in
writing, he could do
multi-digit, multiplication and
division absolutely fine.
And what was even more
surprising to us was that
although his language was
terrible, he couldn't read
anymore, he couldn't write
anymore, if you asked him to
read number words like T-W-O
or E-I-G-H-T, he
could do that perfectly.
If you asked him to write these
words, remember, they're
very irregularly spelt.
There isn't another word in
English that gets consonant
W-O, it's pronounced "ooh."
He was absolutely perfect.
But on equivalent words which
weren't in the number domain
like flat or give, or take, he
couldn't read them and he
couldn't write them.
So we thought, well, there's
actually a separate system in
the brain for numbers.
And maybe for arithmetic
as well.
And so that was really how we
got started in this area,
looking at these kind of
dissociations between the
number domain and other
domains of cognition.
Our first paper in this area
was published in 1991.
It wasn't that long ago, no.
BRADY HARAN: Neuroscience is
quite an old science, though.
It's not like, brand new.
It seems extraordinary to me
that in the 1990s, people
still had no grasp of how we
were dealing with something as
fundamental as words
versus numbers.
BRIAN BUTTERWORTH: That's
absolutely right.
People were not really aware of
the difference between the
number domain of memory and
other domains of memory,
except that in the very early
part of the 20th century,
there was a Swedish neurologist
called Henshin,
who actually came to the same
conclusion that we did.
But although his work is often
referred to, it didn't seem to
generate a lot of new studies
in this area.
The left parietal lobe
seemed to be the
key area for numbers.
And if it was damaged,
then you've got
these selective deficits.
If it was preserved, you've
got preserved numerical
capacities.
And if you did the imaging,
what you saw was that in
number tasks, this was the area
that was active when you
were doing the number tasks.
These are the parietal lobes.
These bits around here.
And although you do very simple
number tasks, like
estimate the number of objects
in an array, both in the left
and the right parietal, when
you're doing calculations,
it's mostly in the
left parietal.
So that area there seems
to be the part that's
critical for numbers.
The language areas,
they're here.
This is Wernicke's area, and
this is Broca's area around
about there.
So you can see that
anatomically,
they're rather separate.
BRADY HARAN: The thing that
you've said to me so far that
really strikes me is that my
brain could be damaged in such
a way that I can no longer
function very well with words,
but I will still recognize the
words for numbers, which makes
me think the words for numbers,
to me, aren't really
words at all.
Is that right?
Does my brain not process
E-I-G-H-T as a word?
Does it process it
as a number?
BRIAN BUTTERWORTH: Well, it
interprets it as a number.
So if you still know number
meanings, then you can process
E-I-G-H-T. So the neurological
patient who could read and
write E-I-G-H-T, but not a
word like G-A-V-E, gave--
although he had this
word in his brain.
We know he had the word in his
brain because we asked him to
say whether G-A-V-E
was a real word.
He would say yes, it is.
What does it mean?
He didn't know.
How do you pronounce it?
He couldn't do it.
Can you write it?
He couldn't write it.
It was in his brain, but
he didn't have an
interpretation for it.
So he only had interpretations
for number words.
So they were the words that
he could pronounce.
They were the words he
could understand.
The other words, although they
were still in his brain , he
couldn't do anything
with them.
BRADY HARAN: What do I
do for big numbers?
BRIAN BUTTERWORTH: Well, you
make an estimate which is
based on extracting
various visual
properties from the stimulus.
And there's now some brilliant
work done by Marco Zorzi's lab
in Italy, where they've modeled
how this might work.